just gonna recommend to any young comics
it's you know it's
it's not politically correct to say but
it's a good idea when you start doing
comedy just
find someone who has a job who you can
live off
[Music]
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 119.
clearly my studio still isn't set up
although this is an ipad and looks
pretty good long story short i'm
allergic to tennessee nashville was
amazing i just moved to franklin but i
forgot i'm basically a bubble person and
there's greenery everywhere and so i'm
allergic to everything i may be moving
to a desert maybe i'll live in a yurt
probably be allergic to the dust
anyway i don't know if you can tell my
face is puffy
i have other allergy symptoms but i
can't do it
can't do tennessee too many allergies
one day i'll have a studio again
sometime soon in some city somewhere
in this episode i spoke with janice
pappas a comedian from new york city
janice is an american stand-up comedian
actor and podcast host from brooklyn new
york he co-hosted an award-winning
series in the sports comedy show in
addition to participating in festivals
around the world and live shows i liked
him a lot this was a good episode we
spoke about a number of topics including
him getting shot
recovering getting through ptsd
we spoke about the transgender mixed
martial arts fighter who pretty brutally
won an mma fight fighting under the name
lady farrell
with a t-shirt on
that said end transgenocide
while beating up a woman anyway the
conversation gets weird it was fun
please hit subscribe and hit like if you
like it or don't either way i hope you
enjoy the episode
[Music]
papas welcome to my podcast welcome
michaela peterson to
me being a guest on your podcast it's
good to be here i'm excited great well
thank you so much for coming on i'm
excited to talk to you yeah i've seen
your specials i'm a fan thank you so
this should be fun i'm a fan of you i've
been watching uh
the clips from your podcast you've had
some friends of mine on and uh i'm happy
to be here this is amazing and here
means you know
in my house we're doing this virtually
but you know what
i embrace the future
i'm not embracing the future but i'm
making do with what we have for the
moment are you in new york i'm in new
york and we're both two coveted
survivors so it's good to speak to
another coveted survivor i saw you call
covenant in russia
i caught it on the flagrant two podcast
and so we have something in common not
only were north american but we also are
coveted survivors which is good i've had
covid i've had kovad twice i know i saw
that kovan really likes you
well you it does really like me
canadians are just more welcoming
generally so
maybe that's had something to do with
that
i think it's it it was me
pretending kovit doesn't exist really
that made it happen so many times are
you listening to the joe rogan podcast
i do
i do indeed okay
before we get started for anybody who
isn't familiar with your work can you
give a brief background about who you
are and what it is you do i'm a trans
man um
who is living my dream as me no uh i'm a
greek american kid from brooklyn new
york uh i'm a stand-up comic i got a
podcast called long days with giannis
pappas formally i had a podcast called
history hyenas
christos stefano was a lot of fun
and uh i'm just uh i'm just a wild kid
who's uh
who's currently on 10 milligrams of um
of uh i don't even remember what it is
because they call me johnny biden so i
remember i'm on 10 milligrams or
something
lexa pearl lexapro
that's what it is oh man
i took lexapro it did not agree with me
no
no not at all made me really volatile
and i do not need to be more volatile
really are you volatile
very very yeah i did my dad's
personality test i scored 98 on
volatility
wow
at least you didn't at least you didn't
do the robert hair test and come up
psychopath that's the worst one right as
far as personality traits
i would say psychopaths probably not
great yeah well it's not great for other
people but for the psychopath it's
that's true you live unencumbered by uh
guilt and i just that's true freedom now
if you think about who the freest people
on the planet are it's probably
psychopaths because they don't
they don't have any feelings so they're
totally free of any commitments or
emotions
that's a free life
that is a free life yeah that is a free
life i've actually considered that
before not having the guilt or that that
voice in your head that tells you when
things are you're doing things wrong
yeah that actually doesn't sound half
bad for you can i ask you a question if
like they figure out a way to do brain
surgery and take out that emotion which
they'll probably be able to do at some
point would you have it removed would
you become a psychopath
i'm curious
you know what i because of the amount of
guilt that i'm experiencing now no i
wouldn't be able to go through with it
right so my current personality would
stop that from happening i would just be
too curious i'd have to do it i'd have
to do it and then i just couldn't wait
to look at myself in the mirror to just
see the depth in my eyes and i would
just look at myself and go cool and then
i'd go out the world and destroy
have some fun i think they have the real
fun
i think they probably do
well no no i would say maybe not maybe
maybe you don't get the positives
associated with it maybe that's why you
have to do more extreme behaviors in
order to experience joy properly
yeah but i mean what's more lit that or
just like
sitting around thinking of weighing
consequences i think skydiving sounds a
lot more lit i mean we can ask you pops
he probably knows because he's probably
sat down with a few but
they just have a lit time i mean yeah
occasionally they'll bite off the titty
but you know that's not all of them
that's just like a few of them who go
awry you know
just don't get in the face yeah if
somebody asks you to get in the backseat
of a beagle and they're pretending to
have a an arm injury just don't get in
ladies you may lose a titty
wise words wise it's all you really i
mean that's all you really need to know
to have a safe life
stay away from someone who's injured
asking you to get to help them put
something in their car
oh man i'd fall for that you fell
through the 10 bundy one two
oh instantly yeah
like oh no an injury
i've been there i can help
but what would it be because of his
looks or would it be because you just
felt bad
oh well looks would definitely come into
play yeah he was a pretty handsome devil
to be honest with you
for sure i might have helped him out too
be honest
yeah there you go yeah are you able to
do shows in new york right now i am i am
able to do shows i'm a little concerned
i have a newborn uh 11 months old so i'm
a little concerned um not really in new
york but like i cancelled my texas in
florida dates because i'm a [ __ ]
and uh
i care about my daughter god damn
so uh yeah i'm just you know until
there's like more data about like how it
affects kids and stuff like that but
it's looking pretty good i i read some
study it was a small study of like only
a few kids but
they were like in the icu with covet and
no long-term effects a year later so
that's good so i'll probably go down to
uh to florida in texas or as they like
to call it the real america
and do shows soon but i did postpone
those shows but i am now getting back
out on the road and new york is like
yeah the new york's wide open you can do
shows now they you have to show your
passport though there's somebody at the
door who was let me see your papers
says here going to switzerland i don't
think so mr greenberg
and
dr george
[Laughter]
that so they're actually doing that in
new york yeah they're about to do that
in ontario i think at the end of
september yeah
yeah i mean you know i talked to i i
talked to like doctors like this one
doctor i talked to who's like a g he's
brilliant he's a surgeon and he's the
republican which is
uh why i trust him in this you know
because like if anyone's gonna be
conspiratorial it's usually that side
with this
and he's like yeah man you know it's a
dangerous bug and you know he's like for
the
the mandates because people aren't
getting the vaccine because he's like
that's the only thing that's going to
end this pandemic so it's like but then
i listen to people who turn covet into
content and they're saying something
different so i don't know who to trust
people not on the internet or people on
the internet
nobody absolutely nobody yeah i didn't i
didn't trust anyone but i've had covered
twice and the second time was pretty
rough my best friend it's kovitz all
over toronto right now my best friend's
kid uh he's six months old he just
caught it so both his parents were
vaccinated but he's little so he wasn't
vaccinated and
dad this is just this is interesting
it's just anecdotal but the dad was
vaccinated with pfizer and he got quite
ill mom with moderna no symptoms and
then little levi got sick but he was
sick for like
two days with a tiny bit of a fever and
they gave him tylenol and he's better
now and now he's probably immune for a
while so yeah that's my anecdotal
study on on vaccines well i guess the
the main thing is that they're all okay
no big deal for anyone yeah that's the
point yeah yeah
that's they're all fine
i was just in austin checking it out as
i was considering moving i don't want to
be in canada anymore i'm tired of canada
do you have your cell yeah do you have
your uh what is it i know you guys got
to pay like 10 grand
to get your uh
the 01 001
it's in the works yeah
so yeah it's coming good um but i can be
there for six months
hanging out
before that comes in so that that'll
come in but i was looking at austin
because i have a whole bunch of friends
moving to austin and i was there last
month and i
really didn't like it
yeah i don't like it either i was
considering a move for a second you know
because after i did rogan i was and new
york was shut right yeah i was like ah
maybe i'll move down he's like i'm open
to the club man and uh it's gonna be
great it's gonna be a comedy mecca
and uh then i spent some time there and
uh you know i got you know homeless
people throwing bricks at me
and uh i was like well i'm kidding but i
mean there's the homeless are like it's
like a
zombie apocalypse down there
in downtown and i was like i don't know
if i could do this man i'm from new york
this is i'm used to a really nice city
we're just i was new yorkers are
arrogant we're arrogant we are
for good reason though or or is that
just because everyone else there is good
reason i think i mean let's be honest
you like every but you're from new york
so you would say you'd say that i'm
biased yeah but i mean like there's a
reason why everyone wants to come here
at least pre-covet i mean you know it's
every other city kind of looks like new
york new york uh the casino in vegas to
us we go there and we're like wow look
at you these are your skylines and we
like pat them on the head they're like
there's something new nice little job
kansas city
it's just it's new york is a universe
crammed into one and then you go to
another city and you do the downtown
like in a day and you're like that's it
and uh yeah so it's tough but if you
like barbecue food
and only barbecue food austin's your
spot
now i'm gonna go to nashville
nashville's a good one
i've made my decision yeah yeah
nashville's a good one that's a
beautiful town
i know i love it i'm currently wearing
cowboy boots do you like do you like
country music my wife loved like she's
just like a big fan of country music
uh
i like old country i don't know about
the new i don't know right maybe one day
i will when i'm there and it's
everywhere constantly right
right yeah
yeah well you got one of the biggest
country singers
ever right
shania twain shania
this is true yeah
you guys can really
you blend it in with us
you know you guys are like
you really sneaky canadians are sneaky
you'll meet one and i'll be like hey
you're american and then as soon as
that's why i force everyone i suspect is
canadian and i always say i suspect
someone's canadian because you guys have
like a molested blow like a nice thing
you got like that i'm in a cult look in
your eyes
and so if i see that in the eyes i
suspect is this person canadian and you
can't tell until you hit an a or an
about so i usually try to frame them a
question where i know an about's going
to come in and then i'm like gotcha
gotcha you canuck
ah i don't think i sound canadian you
don't that's why you're about yeah yeah
you guys blend right in
like cia agents
which is convenient for your spies for
justin trudeau
yeah no hell no hell no
okay i want some background information
on you like let's do it when did you get
started how soon did you make comedy a
full-time
thing i had like a very uh
very jagged
journey it didn't it wasn't a straight
line like anything in my life so
two steps forward ten steps back
you know i started like in 2000 doing
stand-up then
2001 in may and i was off to like an
auspicious start like i started hitting
the road i was doing colleges i was
having fun
uh the the the gl ones just came out so
me and my buddy started filming and we
were doing that before anybody on the
internet and then i got shot in um 2001
in a robbery uh attempted robbery at a
nightclub that i was working at you know
i was just trying to make cash doing
comedy and then uh were you doing
security no i was working um yeah i mean
if i did security i mean rob that club
i was working like uh you know he
created like some [ __ ] jobs for me
because he's a friend of mine he was the
promoter and his parties were like
really like
you know it was all like drug dealers
and you know people would i did the cash
register so people would come in i just
remember dudes just pulling out wads of
money and you know it was that type of
party um
the place i got shot at actually uh
another fame infamous thing happened
where there was this famous director he
might have been canadian i don't
remember if i'm thinking right but he
was walking home one night in soho
and outside of this club i used to work
at and this can be googled and people
can read about it's a crazy story
somebody shot somebody in their car and
then the guy tried to drive away while
he was shot and he died behind the wheel
and this director like whose career was
just taking off was just walking home
and the guy who's dead in his car got
shot hit him and killed him randomly and
that was that was the club i was working
at so that i got shot
you know it was kind of a milieu of that
spot
it was a dangerous spot yeah
so jeez that was that how long did it
yeah how long did it take you to recover
from that it was quick i mean i got so
what happened was um
you know some some guy like tried to rob
us and i got shot point blank range like
in the car
and um
yeah and it was like in my upper inner
thigh
and uh
i could i stayed overnight in the
hospital but it missed all the there's
like a main artery there it didn't hit i
was lucky
and um
you know i had a very beautiful doctor
digging in my [ __ ] to find if it was
compromised in any way that was
embarrassing
like when i got to the emergency room
you know she just like to check if how
to make it worse yeah it's just the
whole like on top of it yeah and you
know what i learned though i really and
i don't know if i've ever talked about
this i learned how women must feel and i
mean this
i learned how women must feel when like
they're assaulted or something like that
because cops are they're very
insensitive like when they come to get
the story like when a crime happens
i remember like because i was shot the
cops just assumed because usually people
who get shot are involved in some
service shady stuff
so they were just like making up stuff
trying to catch me in a lie they were
like he said
because they caught the guy they were
like he said this was part of he was the
kid was like i don't know armenia in a
row so he was like uh this was some sort
of greek armenian beef or something i
was like no he was like he said
he said if you would have said
if if if i would have said what he said
you would have done the same thing so
like what'd you say to him i was like i
don't know who the kid is
this is you know and they just didn't
believe me and they were making jokes
with the
with the bedpan they were like look
captain he's got look at if he can put
it on his head he's got a nice hat and
i'm sitting there just like shot
and um so when they try to get the story
it's like they're they're very
insensitive so i could just imagine
being a woman going in there telling
their story and they're like yeah but
like you know did you know the guy what
were you wearing you know did it i could
just kind of picture that that
insensitivity maybe now things have
changed because of charlie's angels and
and um and the me too movement i call it
charlie's angels where they're just
[ __ ] girls activate and get everybody
i feel like things have probably changed
that sounds miserable it was especially
wow yeah because i feel like how long
yeah sorry
no no you go ahead i was just saying my
feelings were yeah i was like in a
vulnerable position and like
you know you're just sitting there and
how old were you i was 23
oh yeah yeah
that's that's pretty young for that to
happen yeah and so i was just like one
like the cops were
like being skeptical of my story and i
was like dude you know
you know but i get it can i just heal
and go home can i just yeah really can
you just hand me a lollipop and make me
feel better
call my mommy and tell her to come
yeah jeez so how long did it take did i
mean how much of a hiatus did you take
after that so it was interesting so
i just kind of like they let me go the
next day and then like i couldn't really
sit on a toilet or anything for a while
because it was so sore they left the
bullet in because it was too deep in so
they were just like we're just going to
leave it in and then eventually your
body will push it out like you know i
guess your body seriously yeah
yeah
what i didn't know that that was a thing
that
they actually did yeah that seems like
the wrong thing to do yeah it does seem
like the wrong thing to do like hey get
this out of me but
apparently your body will slowly reject
a foreign object and push it out like
your body knows and that's kind of what
happened like it would it slowly made
its way to the surface where you could
like feel it and then i got it removed
like two two years later
um
so
i i yeah i was home and and then uh and
then i i had an snl audition
i just started comedy and i got an i had
an snl audition like that week so i did
it
i did it like four days after getting
shot and it was we like i didn't know
the psychological effects of this thing
like ptsd
i mean my yeah so i went on stage and
like i bombed i like completely bombed
and like i was like
i was like kind of having these physical
reactions like you know shaking and
hyperventilating and i didn't know what
they were i wasn't connecting the two
and that went on for like a like a like
a a while like a year
um
and i didn't know
i couldn't connect the two uh that i had
ptsd because then i started like i get
on the train and i just start
hyperventilating and having a panic
attack i get off and i go what is going
on like i didn't know yeah and i guess i
went from this
state of like this benign denial of
never thinking something like that could
happen to like my brain going to the
opposite extreme going like wow this
could happen at any time and i was just
my subconscious was like freaking out so
i went to therapy and i i got over it
but you know anxiety's been a part of my
life ever since thanks for opening that
door whoever the kid was who shot me
yeah that's terrible
yeah wow so i quit comedy for a little
while
yeah okay well that's not that
surprising
uh the first time
so i was quite sick when i was young and
i when i got better
i started having
this had never happened to me but i
started having panic attacks when i went
into hospitals and
just from the association of that and
surgery
and so the first time i went into a
hospital and it there wasn't like a
really a mental component exactly but i
went to a hospital and i was like
i had that like physical thing happening
i was like what is happening
oh
that's like panic just from like my body
doing that it was very strange did you
have like an advantage because of your
dad that he'd let you know early what it
was or
so i told him i was like i can't go into
hospitals i don't know what to do like
if i go into a hospital or even anything
i was pregnant at the time when that
really started happening so even going
to the midwife just because it was
peripherally associated with the
hospital i'd get this panicky feeling
again and i was like dad what do i do do
i need to do like exposure therapy and
like
walk around hospitals for a while and
like go in them slowly
and and he was like no given what
happened to you that's totally a
reasonable response
i was like
okay well i guess i'll just figure this
out on my own thanks dad
it's amazing how weird how sensitive we
are like as humans we're just like these
emotional like
like a psychopaths don't feel anxiety at
all they don't fear feel fear that's why
it's so free to be one
but it's just amazing like nothing's
happening we're not nothing we're not
in danger at all and we freak out like
we do because we get these big brains
and we're [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah well
also some of these things you can kind
of logic out you're like well i
shouldn't have had that kind of response
but something like
having surgery or what happened to you
it's pretty reasonable for your body to
be like nope
make sure that never happens again that
seems like a pretty reasonable response
yeah to me yeah i mean you would figure
your mind would just be like you're okay
though your mind would but i guess
that's how strong the subconscious is
because i didn't know what it was until
a therapist started pointing out i
remember like the city you know because
the city pays for your you know uh the
vic there's some victim fund where like
you're victim of a crime you go to the
hospital it's paid for by the city and
then they offer you like counseling
and uh and i was like why do i need to
kill yeah i was like i'm fine i feel
fine and then
a year later i mean i was dealing with
these panic attacks
for like a full year and uh yeah
whenever i'd go on stage i started
freaking out i'd be sweating and
hyperventilating and so i just kind of
quit
and then i did something a little more
relaxing which was social work with 9 11
victims and then i started having more
panic attack
and i took on their anxiety
it's brutal brutal time it was a dark
time
ah yeah that doesn't sound here just
relax don't go on stage in front of a
bunch of people deal with trauma victims
yeah
you needed to be like in a cottage
somewhere at a beach
breathing for a while resetting your
nervous system yeah
yeah i started i did social work then
for about five years and
yeah that uh they just threw me in there
at the beginning and i remember like one
of my first clients was uh a waiter or
no he was a pastry chef at windows on
the world and they like oh he lost all
his friends he was off duty that day and
the first day i pulled we were like
talking he was like cause i was a
caseworker he just started crying to me
in the
in the room we were in and it was my
first like day
and i was like wow like
i was so detached like
it forced me to grow up faster than
than um
i should have probably and i think it
was just too much and so
it was just overwhelming emotionally and
i just went into a dark place and i
think it's called counter transference
or something where like you take on the
anxiety of your clients like you you
know if you're in social work or you do
any type of health care i don't i can't
remember the term for it but i remember
i would have anxiety going to sleep
because i was like helping people get
mortgage rental assistance
um victims compensation fund um we had
something so i worked with people who
lost their husbands lost their jobs lost
their livelihood lost their whatever
family members the breadwinners
and then there was something called the
unmet needs table where you would
present the client's case to all these
charities like a group of charities and
then based on what you were asking for
they decide what to give and i remember
going to sleep worried about like i
gotta get this person's rent paid or
mortgage paid so i kind of took on their
anxiety it was a dark time
that is an insane job yeah it was wild
that sounds like you might be so that
personality test i was i'm obsessed with
this personality test this understand
myself that my dad's made i've been
using it since before it was on the
internet giving it to like potential
boyfriends judging them harshly
i'm dead serious about that too but
it sounds like you probably scored high
on compassion
you can say counter whatever but people
who don't score as high usually
are a little bit more detached so you
might have felt detached but like if you
were taking on people's if you cared
that much
you might have scored higher on
compassion yeah
even though you're a comedian yeah
yeah because i've been in comedy a long
time i'll tell you there's two types of
personalities i've noticed in comedy
either
extreme empaths like very sensitive or
like yeah or like dictator level
sociopaths nothing in between
yeah that that seems accurate yeah
that's what i've noticed if you think
about it it's a job that's very similar
to a dictator you stand in front of the
crowd you you woo them you get them to
follow you
uh you know
you lie make up stories
and uh
charisma lots of charisma
you know we have a lot in common with
with uh asocial types
so huh yeah maybe it's a different way
of reading the crowd like maybe people
who are less agreeable or less
compassionate
do something more charismatic and do a
different type of read than people who
are empathetic or empaths and then maybe
they can feel the crowd more not sure
how
that would work yeah that's a good
question i wonder that's why i'd love to
get into the mind as someone who who's
look seeking to control more than to
connect because they both work they both
work very well
you know
interesting yeah i've met somebody okay
so
sorry no no you've met some no i was
just gonna say i met some comics
who uh you meet them off stage and then
you see them on stage and you're like oh
that's not you at all
and it's like it's all a method it's all
thought out and pretty meditated it's
marketing you know it's a it's what
madison avenue has been doing for us you
know smoker you know oh like pure like
acting right you were like yes
sociopathy
yeah like kind of like there's that's
not the person at all you know look at
bill cosby i mean for example you know
i mean evil people always pretend to be
the opposite of what they are nobody
comes into a room and announces i'm hey
i'm gonna
you know it's like if you hide behind
i'm clean
i'm wholesome look what the catholic
church does you know it's like call me
father
uh you know make sure you confess to me
so i have things to blackmail you with
if you try to you know if you find out
what i've been doing i mean you know
it's uh we we're holy we're good and
it's like they've just been mass raping
kids it's like it's uh evil people it's
always the wolf in sheep's clothing
that's how evil operates they never walk
in and announce their evil or else
they'd be
caught
yeah true that's not good marketing no
stop i'm the evil sociopath trust me
yeah that's not gonna happen yeah
that's what makes them so fun
yeah that's true that's true so
you did get back into comedy so how did
that start
um it started slow like i started uh
i was doing social work uh at that point
i had like done i was working for an ad
hoc agency for 911 relief called uh
ldrny and that was over
two and a half two and a half years i
did that so around 2005
i was getting unemployment and that ran
out and then i started working with
mentally ill informally homeless people
in an sro which is a new york thing and
then i slowly started doing a show once
a week with uh donnell rawlings who was
really the guy who got me back in his
stand up and i always give him credit
for that and he was if you don't know
who he is he was like ashley larry on
the chappelle show and now he tours with
chappelle all the time
and um
that was right when chappelle show
was coming on the air
and then it hit big and so he took me on
the road with him and burr and charlie
murphy and i would like to sell his
posters and do five minutes
and um
and so that he got me back into he kind
of pulled me into it tell me i was funny
and he gave me the opportunity to
perform in one of his like rooms that he
had in manhattan once a week so i
started doing comedy once a week again
and then slowly i met more people
started doing more shows and i got back
into it that way so that was about 2006
and um so that's when i really started
again
and started like for for real you know
started going after and then i went full
time in 2008 i quit and i just lived off
my girlfriend at the time so
okay so since 2008 so that's quite a
while yeah
i recommend okay so how do you
sorry i was just gonna recommend to any
young comics it's you know it's
it's not politically correct to say but
it's a good idea when you start doing
comedy just
find someone who has a job who you can
live off of
i'm gonna clip that yeah
uh
when you do sets
do you come up with a whole like
storyline of kind of what you're going
to say and you have jokes that are in
your head or are you is it really on the
fly i'm always curious how comics can go
on stage and tell
you know story after little story after
story after story after story and
remember what to say next
i think uh there's two types of comics
i mean there's variation between those
two types but
it's really the comics who write their
jokes beforehand
like um they write them down and then
like go perform them and then there's
comics who write while they're on stage
who take a premise and that's what i am
i'm a comic who writes on stage so i
take a premise something that in my head
i think is funny or something i say to
someone who i think is funny
uh and then i just take it on stage and
play with it and then little by little
you craft it that way like a sculptor
you just kind of change a word here
and your goal is just
really democracy it's like the you want
you can't get everybody but you're
looking for
the most to appeal to the most people to
get the biggest laughs in that area so
you craft it
around that that's what you have and you
can really only do that
on stage so i think even the people who
write beforehand once they test it
they'll go back and rewrite it and tweak
and that's what comics do you just tweak
it to make it the most appealing to the
most amount of people
well it's no wonder you have some
anxiety that sounds anxiety provoking it
is very anxiety it's you know it's the
biggest fear people have for a reason
you know it's public speaking especially
if you think about we're expected i
think somebody
some egghead timed it out like about
every eight seconds you're expected a
laugh in order to do good so uh yeah
speaking
publicly is nerve-racking enough but
when you're expected to get a laugh like
every eight seconds
at minimum it uh yeah it takes a while
we all are like turtles i mean comics of
like and that's what you build up over
years is just a thick skin
so uh you know whenever i read my
youtube comments and someone says like
my eyes are too close together like i
just love it i love
you know i love being made fun of i mean
you could say anything to me i mean i've
we publicly are rejected it's the only
art form where you practice in public
and the audience tells you in real time
you get rejected in real time you can
hear it and you can see it in their face
you know other artists go in their room
and they practice practice practice and
then they present
uh you know somewhat of a finished
product we are
always on display
that's a very good point that's a very
good point i didn't think i like i
figured i mean if you're singing or
something it's a song that you've
recorded in studio and then you've
practiced it
so many times that almost everything is
perfect and so
that's completely different than on the
fly trying to make people laugh
oh yeah
yeah
so i'm that ladder type of comic where i
just i wing it a lot i wing it a lot um
and
things will come to me in the moment
necessity's the mother of invention so
it's a real tightrope walk i guess i
prefer that
and uh you go out there you try
something and um you know it works or it
doesn't and um then you craft it based
on that the next show and the next show
and the next show and now with
podcasting i feel like
i feel like comedy's changing too and
you're going to see certain comics
like who can do a podcast like you see
you know tim do you know i i have a
similar style to tim where it's like we
just rant for like an hour
and uh you you sometimes you watch a tim
dillon episode you'll be like that was
as good as any crafted special
i've seen so it's like
because of the internet and because of
how fast things moves now now and how
many things have already been done
maybe that's changing maybe like
stand-up will become more like riffing
in the moment uh current events things
like that because i mean
we're kind of like running out of [ __ ]
you know it's like everything's been
done
oh but the world is changing so quickly
there's so much new content that's true
but if but it what's relevant today
you'd be surprised it used to be you can
have an hour for like
two two years and then and then record
it and it would still feel kind of
relevant now things move so fast that
you're kind of like you hot you have a
bit and you're like
or you go and you look at twitter and
you're like there's 20 people doing
tweets about that premise and you know
it's like
so it is a little bit more of a
challenge in that way you know what i
mean because you're like the world moves
so fast and there's so many people
tweeting and so many people consider
themselves funny and yeah there's more
than just stand-ups now so we used to
have a monopoly on funny that we don't
have anymore
that is very true that's very true even
with podcasting if you want to hop on
something
you have to find like for me if i'm
trying to comment on something i have to
find someone record it i have
eric
his team editing it and then release it
right away and learn about it yeah
you're right that is tricky and things
do age quickly it's like some some
controversy like two months ago it's
like oh no people already freaked out
and
rioted and protested and now they're
over and on to the next thing and that's
that's done now
yeah
that's why i sometimes suspect that we
may be coming to the end because you
know
you know when you drop an apple from uh
from wherever
you know
up high
the farther it falls the quicker it
falls and so i feel like we're about to
hit that ground because things are
moving
real quick they've sped up so
i hope it's not over i got a kid
but it's a little yeah it's a little
scary you know there's this push to get
off the planet
it's like you know these elites you're
like what do they know
what do they know like
you know
they're just like they're trying to skip
town
i'm trying to skip town i don't know
anything i'm just like i'm not
comfortable in toronto maybe nashville's
nashville will be nice and comfortable
for a while
before that angst gets there
yeah i mean don't you feel like the news
is a little apocalyptic now it's like
reading the bible every morning it's
like fire here
flood here riots here
you're like what's going on man
it's weird and i almost feel like these
elites like bezos and they're like
they're like on the lifeboats of the
titanic they've like taken the few of
the lifeboats and they're just like
rowing away
you
know like we saw this coming a long time
ago we have life boats for myself all
our friends some yachts see you guys
yeah
i see that i see that for sure we'll see
maybe things will improve maybe things
will things are either going to like i
don't think they're going to stay like
this they're either going to improve
like the economy is going to open up
like we'll either get used to covet or
or it'll get less bad or things are
going to get way worse
i don't see like uh i don't see us
hovering around this weird
level we're at now for very long people
are too
angsty
i've thought that for a while
you know especially with like how zany
the left has got and
in some ways how zany the right is god
i'm like this can't last forever maybe
this is just no people uh you know i
think it's
people struggling to adapt to something
as powerful as the internet we've never
had anything like this
where information there's so much
information coming at you this fast
such a pure democratic medium where
everyone has a voice and it's people are
just adapting to the power of it but
every time i'm like ah it's coming to an
end i read the news and it's like yeah
you know
trans woman who was a man a year ago
just
choked out a woman in mma i'm like this
is getting wild
this is getting wild i saw that that's
wild that's wild yeah
it is wild you know and you know it's
funny nobody ever really talks about the
point like
it's like how come you never hear any
controversy about
trans men trying to compete with men if
there's no advantage to being a
biological man why aren't there
all these trans men
protesting to get into men's sports
because guess what
men would welcome it if there is a trans
man if elliott paige can cover odell
beckham jr in the open field
god bless him
you know some little five six
trans men who was born a biological
woman who's just you know they always
got that voice like hey i'm a trans man
how are you doing my name is buck
if those men can compete with
male pro athletes
god bless them but obviously the point
is they can't they can't because
when you're a man
you just you have an advantage
physically that a trans man could never
catch up to at the pro level
yeah i know i don't know like i see news
articles like that where it's like
yeah like
that
that that woman mma fighter she got like
fairly hurt and it was like
duh like if we can't recognize that
that's gonna happen as a society
not very smart
yeah um it's a
yeah i mean i get it people want to be
compassionate they want to understand
but like but it's not compassionate to
let somebody get beaten no it's not and
especially when that i think he picked
the you know she i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
on notice i put myself on notice i'm
sorry i misgendered her
she was like he
a year ago i took up mma a year ago from
what i read
and then competed like in a pro mma
fight against women
you're like
what are we doing and they test i guess
they test the levels i mean i'm no
scientist but it's like yeah but it's
not all about i mean that's silly too it
feels like there's no scientist behind
that because you can't just test a level
of a hormone be like okay it's even now
like yeah what about all the muscle
growth and the bone structure and the
shoulder width and like what about
everything else that has to do with it
instead of this one like marker that can
be like kind of artificially suppressed
right yeah you're right it's like they
cherry pick the one thing
and if you see a before picture of that
girl that trans woman who just choked
out that woman in an mma fight in
portland of course um or oregon um
he was buff i mean he was like a big
dude so it's funny like the before and
after picture
he was a big guy and then yes so
it's uh
it's a wild time it's a wild time we're
kind of living in an impressionist
painting where
all lines have been
diluted all form is gone anything goes
and uh anyone could be whatever they
want it's uh you know i guess america
really is the land of opportunity you
can
you know only in this country can you be
born a woman and grow up
only in this country could you be born a
man and then grow up to be a female
champion
you can be anything you want in america
oh
brutal i was uh my dad was pretty
unhappy with that he tweeted something
out about it and was like yeah
yeah people should be unhappy i don't
think things are gonna change until like
there's something that really
really unpleasant that happens to like
somebody in high school
and then their parents go okay
yeah something needs to change you know
unfortunately
i gotta say this is a women's issue you
know it's like i know women this is like
women's like we don't men you know i
gotta i got enough to worry about i got
i gotta get calling i gotta get colon
checked i you know
this is for women because like i said
this isn't that we we don't have that
that we don't have that problem where
like there's trans men trying to compete
with men and if they did we would
welcome it because that would be amazing
if they could do it yeah so it's like
yeah women got to uh it just shows you
how divided women are
yeah
strange too because i feel like and
well i feel like that that that whole
issue was kind of brought
forward by women as well so like
i i think more than i mean it was
brought forward by a lot of people but i
feel like the forefront of bringing it
forward kind of like women wanting
this and now
i don't know we'll see what happens i'm
gonna watch from the sidelines
comment now and then hopefully nobody
gets really hurt it's a it just shows
you how things are finite the more
extreme you go in one direction you come
out the other side the universe is
finite yeah there's a finite amount of
notes there's a finite amount of ideas
because feminism now if you go all the
way to the extreme of feminism
you're basically advocating for a man to
go into a female space after he
transitions so you're going like you've
come back to the other side
like miss pac-man
[Laughter]
huh yeah that's why
extremists have so much in common that
they don't acknowledge
that they just go full circle yeah in
kind of every aspect whatever the
extreme is yeah that's super weird that
that happens
that's very true yeah you have to be
careful you have to be careful
if you're if you're really i've found
that because i've had i mean i feel like
everybody has this problem when they're
too attached to one idea it's like as
soon as you're super super attached
you're like oh yeah i'm 100 certain
about this one idea then you have to
kind of check yourself and say well
maybe there's something i'm missing
because i probably shouldn't be 100
certain about anything that's a great
point yeah
that's a great point that because then
you get blind you become arrogant and uh
you become blind that's what happens to
powerful people that's what
that's why uh scientists the scientific
method is the best way because it's
always about
amending and
[Music]
changing and
uh
so
yeah i mean the secret you know socrates
nailed that it's like you know always
question
you know always i'm dumb you know
because you are i mean look how big and
vast the universe are we're dumb
yes
you're that
okay
who are your favorite comics these days
um
well he's a good friend of mine um but
tim dillon i think is doing uh
something nobody's doing with podcasts
for sure
he's uh off the fly he's just
he's he's funny and he's just so
naturally talented and smart he's fun
um
uh you know bill burr who's one of my
favorites as a stand-up
um and in anything
um
patrice o'neill was one of my favorites
the late great patrice o'neill was was
great
but there's so many that are good now uh
you know nate parket's a great clean
comic and just so funny and
there's guys like dan soder paul verzi
there's so many funny guys now
but my favorites of all time george
carlin was the guy i saw
yeah yeah i saw his special you're all
diseased in 1999 it was after his wife
died so he was like
you could tell he was like he put
everything
i don't know what he considered his
magnum opus but i consider that to be
his best special
he was he was surly but not to the point
where it wasn't funny anymore like
towards the end he got like like bill
hicks towards the end you're going like
is this comedy or you just
you know are you just angry but it had
that perfect balance of like
bitterness and
humor and it was just he was just so
brilliant george carlin and prolific
so uh there's a lot jackie gleason
there's a little people a lot a lot of
people don't know about him because he
was he was a long time ago but he was
just gifted and a lot of people don't
know he was a stand-up and he would go
on you know go into rooms with no
material and just rip the room and
shreds and the place would be shaking
just because he had so much talent
you know he used to go into uh the
honeymooners
um which was a failure at the time which
is hilarious it bombed and then it
became a
hit afterwards
but um
he would go in and he would read the
script once and this was back this
before digital right so it's like you
would film was expensive they shot on
film so like you had to nail the lines
he would read the script once no
rehearsal and go
and then you you can watch the episodes
and see what he did he would memorize it
i mean a guy was just
he was brilliant wow yeah he would
before
he would drink like a hundred vodkas he
would eat like a million steaks he was a
very big personality
and uh you know even bob he was
nicknamed the great one because he was
just the talent was just overwhelming of
jackie gleason
so okay
i have to check him out i haven't seen
him yeah
he's dead but i saw
yeah yeah uh i saw i saw bill burr live
uh once i think it was in budapest and i
almost died
he's like i almost died i couldn't
breathe
he's so ridiculous he he could be the
best i mean also chappelle
and then a one that one that's often
overlooked and i'm not gonna say for bad
reason because i've seen him so many
times live and it's really uh
it's really uh it's a crap shoot whether
you get a good show or a drunk one but
doug stanhope
live
when he's on when everything clicks
because you know he's a bit of a drinker
um but when he is on
his brain he's just incredible so he's
uh he's definitely up there for me too
doug stanhope
okay i'm gonna remember that list and
i have some catching up to do i think
if you want to watch doug's dan hope it
was his showtime special called no
refunds it's one of the best specials
you'll ever see
and then patrice o'neil uh elephant in
the room which was the one he did like
right before he died there is good
that's as good as comedy can get right
there
okay
okay
that sounds good
so normally like with when covid isn't a
thing what what do your days look like
like how often do you perform how often
do you go to do comedy shows even now
let's say now because this is the new
how we live now so let's say now
the um
the pandemic changed things for me
um because
before it was like we'd be out every
night doing sets set after set after set
and then the pandemic hit and we all
kind of focus on the internet or at
least the ones who were smart or you
know were were
willing to adapt
and um
now i'm more concerned about my podcast
than i am about sets it's like i'll go
do an hour like i'll go on the road and
because special doesn't mean what it
used to mean you know it used to be like
you did your sets to get a late night
set on a late night television show or
to do a half hour on comedy central or
an hour somewhere but now like we were
talking about before it's so saturated
there's so many comics so many specials
so much content
nobody's watching television anymore
people only watch joke by joke really
that um when i go perform live i just
i'm i just have more fun i riff a lot
and i don't think about my hour and
crafting as much as i used to and i
focus more on my podcast and i put
effort into that researching and
thinking about what the joke's going to
be on there because you just you reach
more people and then you know you build
a fan base and then you go perform for
your fan base i mean the entertainment
industry has exploded into a million
pieces and nobody's really famous
anywhere you're just kind of famous to
the people who know you we're all like
touring bands that have fans
and um i love it it's better that way
there are no more matt damon's
yeah
that's very strange and i guess that's
just because anybody
can try right anyone you don't have to
get a spot on a set or get a position as
an actor you can start creating content
and then see if people like it yeah the
gatekeepers have been usurped they've
been uh rendered
unimportant by the internet it used to
be all you wanted to do is get passed at
a club so then you could work at that
club you can work on your act so you can
get on late night to get that exposure
or get a special and now you just you
know i could i put a video up the other
day of
hitler preparing you know for his speech
in the mirror and you know 70 000 people
saw it or whatever it's like
i thought of that in three seconds
because i shaved my mustache like that
so things move quick now and
you know
comics have to adapt and a lot of
stand-ups haven't because stand-ups are
especially if you're like my age like in
between the eras you know well like it
was it was that era and now it's the
internet a lot of people didn't adapt
and you know a lot of people they don't
understand that you know survival of the
fittest
isn't the strongest survive people
always that's a myth it's the ones who
adapt the best who survive it's not the
strongest it's the ones best suited for
that new environment and in fact a lot
of times within that species when a
change in the environment happens the
ones who were weak in the previous
environment will actually be the ones
who adapt best to the new environment
and those previously strong ones die out
so
um it's all about adapting to the
internet now and the ones who aren't are
just gonna die off and they're dying off
and that the that stand-ups have ceded
the internet to everybody else because
of the stubbornness to
stick to what it was like the purity of
stand-up is is just naive at best and
stupid
at more accurate
yeah you're probably right i think
that's even hitting like even if you go
out of the entertainment industry even
businesses there were businesses
pre-covered that are like oh no no we go
by word of mouth and we have very
specific clientele and they tell our
their friends about us and that's how we
get clients and i can remember talking
to some people being like do you have
instagram to advertise so that people
can find out about you it's like no we
do word of mouth
and then those businesses don't exist
anymore because they're like i don't
want to necessarily say arrogant but
like kind of too arrogant to
lower themselves to social media yeah
nailed it exactly i mean
that's it
yeah yeah so
you have plans for the future other than
focusing on the podcast or is that your
main focus at the moment i hope there is
a future yeah um
if they're the future
[Music]
i mean i'm do i mean the future i mean i
think about this stuff too much but like
i mean the ccp they're no joke they kind
of remind me of the early nazis
and russia kind of reminds me of the
early uh fascists in italy they're kind
of like a there's like a new
uh
you know um
uh alignment going on there's a new uh
those two allies they they kind of
the ccp just feels like they're looking
to dominate that hemisphere
and yeah
what they've done with taiwan under the
cover of covid
by uh you know surreptitiously kind of
taking it with that national security
law
and what they're doing now with uh you
know they have this new policy where
they're they're reigning in the internet
and social media and influencers and
they're uh there's this company bgi
which is a chinese company that was um
supposedly uh doing prenatal tests for
women but it was found out they were
working with the pla the uh military and
they were actually collecting dna to
manipulate it and
try to create like this is a reuters
article this isn't like from you know
newsmax so oh man yeah they were and
looking to manipulate pathogens and
create like super soldiers
you know they must have their own
manifest destiny the way every empire or
rising power does
and we're just so lost in our own bubble
we don't think about them being the new
kid on the block and how they want to
expand and because every growing power
does
and um it's scary i mean we're not
america's not the only superpower
anymore and we don't have a vulnerable
rival like russia was i mean china with
that mixed economy that by any means
you know necessary economy reminds me of
the nazi economy which was very similar
it was like look whatever works markets
socialism community whatever state
controlled whatever works to make us
powerful
military industrial complex whatever it
is we want to we want to grow and that's
what that's what the ccp is doing it's
by any means necessary economy to become
powerful with a mixture of everything
and now they've arrived and um
you know covid was an interesting thing
it was interesting all those protests
were on the street in hong kong their
most coveted thing they want it they
want that one china all these protests
pro-democracy protests there
and then boom covet hits everybody's
inside then boom the national security
law is passed where they surreptitiously
take they take with their allies in hong
kong they take taiwan
and um
i mean pretty much de facto of taking it
it's it's overlooked a lot but they
control they control taiwan now and
you're going like either that's a
coincidence or that was
very opportunistic thinking
when covet hit but it's just uh it's oh
man i don't know anything about this i
need to i need to learn very interesting
[ __ ] yeah
very interesting yeah i'm gonna just add
some extra stress to my life and delve
into that i think it sounds like you
need this is my plan i'm gonna go to
nashville for the winter see how that's
like and then i'm gonna buy like a nice
ranch somewhere
move a whole bunch of people i like
there you're welcome to come if the ccp
comes and everything goes to [ __ ] we'll
just like have a secret
bunker underground just in case out far
from the cities they'll just wait i know
how to shoot a gun i'll be ready i mean
that's what people are doing everyone's
moving to the country and if this is the
new type of warfare if it's like
biological warfare there's because you
know
you can't you can't set off nukes
mutually assure destruction we all know
that you bomb us we bomb you
everything's gone so maybe this is the
new way that war is waged sort of uh
with manipulated pathogens
and that's scary that's scary
yeah that doesn't sound fun yeah okay
on that positive note if people don't
follow you where should they go to
follow you and where can they find your
podcast yeah uh uh you can watch it on
youtube um it's called long days with
giannis pappas and you can get it
wherever you get your podcast long days
with yana's pappas and um you can watch
my special
blowing the light which was produced by
andrew schultz uh that's on youtube for
free
and um and that's really it just go to
those two things and follow me on
twitter giannispappis
and you'll find me
okay i'll link all those below in the
show notes as well if people want to
check them out thank you very much for
coming on thanks that was interesting
thanks nice meeting you nice meeting you
a fan of your comedy thank you thanks
for having me it's a lot of fun
you